hey crazies I said several times that
light doesn't have mass and this is
confused quite a few you for most of you
the issue seems to be doesn't everything
have mass why wouldn't light have it too
or sometimes light has momentum doesn't
that require mass all of which are fair
questions but I think it'll be best to
start with Ashley Hughes who gave this
question some useful context most of the
light arriving on earth from space our
sage comes from the Sun you know that
big glowy ball at the center of the
solar system in the core of the Sun
nuclear fusion is smashing protons
together more details on fusion in an
upcoming video every four protons comes
together to make one helium nucleus but
four protons have more mass than one
helium nucleus about 50 electrons worth
of mass which is enough to worry about
since lots of fusion reactions are
happening inside the Sun all the time
the Sun is losing mass at a rate of
about 4.3 billion kilograms per second
that's three million Jettas per second
which might leave you wondering where
did all that mass go it was released as
light no seriously light is like the
exhaust of the Sun yet it powers our
entire ecosystem how cool is that
but how can mass be lost as light if
light doesn't have mass e equals MC
squared it's energy no no haven't you
said this the energy doesn't disappear
or start floating around on its own it
goes into other atoms molecules or
particles right that energy is contained
by the photons of light but didn't you
also say this there is no difference
between mass and energy oh crap that is
a problem if mass and energy are
equivalent then anything with energy
should have mass light has energy so it
should also have mass
wait wait hold on a second we have to be
really careful about the word mass we
don't want to get it all muddled up with
our preconceived notions let's start
with how we perceive mass because of
general relativity we know light is
affected by gravity which certainly
makes it look like it has mass light can
also create gravity if you have enough
of it you can even create a black hole
it's called a kugelblitz relativity
basically throws mass out the window
gravity is the result of curved
space-time and space-time is curved by
energy momentum pressure and/or stress
not just by mass honestly because of e
equals MC squared you could just as
easily call it mass okay we also know
the more mass of something is the less
willing it is to change how it's moving
that's what we call inertia which we
covered in this video light doesn't ever
change its motion it always travels in
straight lines at a very fast but steady
speed s s so it has infinite inertia and
therefore infinite mass weight that
can't be right hold on we know light has
energy because it has to carry something
away from the nuclear reaction inside
the Sun comes rigid energy Bobby by the
head now momentum is more closely
related to inertia that energy is but we
know light has that too because it can
do this the light collides with the
blades and gives up momentum which makes
the blade spin so light must have
momentum and since it can't have an
infinite amount of momentum it can't
have an infinite amount of inertia
either Oh crisis averted but it has some
inertia though well yes and no when you
think of your own mass you think of all
the stuff that makes up your body it's
something you have even when you're
sitting still what light doesn't ever
sit still ever it's physically
impossible for light now to go with the
speed of light so you can't just equate
the two concepts but but but e equals MC
squared okay we'll take a closer look at
it it's probably the most famous
equation of all time except it's kind of
a lie it actually looks like this where
the letter P stands for momentum from an
old Latin word meaning to go if the
thing isn't moving the equation reduces
to e equals mc-squared if instead
there's no mass the equation reduces to
e equals pc which applies perfectly to
light so light has no matter
some people want e to equal MC squared
so bad they do this where this M is a
rest mass and this M is called
relativistic mass but that's kind of
silly it's much easier just to forget
about mass altogether and use energy and
momentum instead theoretical physicists
did it a long time ago so let me know in
the comments are you satisfied with this
answer or would you rather distinguish
between rest mass and relativistic mass
thanks for liking and sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
in the last video we learned why planets
orbit in a plane comment response time
Jesse Lajeunesse asked the galaxies were
just really big accretion disks yep they
are I can understand me you might think
the physics shouldn't scale up like that
but if it makes you feel any better
that's as far off as it scales you'll
notice galaxy clusters aren't disks the
shape of the large-scale universe
depends on how it originally formed much
more than on conservation of momentum
nunya business was wondering why the
plane of the solar system was roughly
perpendicular to the sun's magnetic
field as it turns out the rotation of
the Sun is roughly parallel to the plane
of the planets which shouldn't be much
of a surprise since it was all rotating
together to begin with but the sun's
magnetic field is generated by
convection currents in its middle layers
how those currents behave depends on the
direction the Sun is spinning so the
magnetic field of the Sun tends to be
perpendicular to its rotation something
that's actually true of planets as well
aimée Soderstrom and megan gilmore while
wondering where the gravity comes from
that collapses the gas cloud in the
first place anything with lots of mass
will create gravity including a very
thin gas cloud it might not have been
very dense but it was big like
light-years across big it contained all
of the mass that will form the Sun the
planets and all the comets and asteroids
that's a lot of mass no matter how dense
it is so the cloud itself creates the
gravity that collapses it to answer k8u
r's questions yes all planetary systems
are discs but they're not all parallel
we've seen a lot of them with telescopes
which just confirms our hypothesis on
how they form but we see them from a
bunch of different angles a lot of them
have stars at their center but others
have multiple stars orbiting a common
center
it depends on the complex details ok
Crazy's the next video is the hundredth
video it might not go up until early
November though there's a lot going on
with me right now there are more details
about that in my most recent vlog click
anywhere on my face or the mobile card
somewhere up there yeah in case you
didn't know I have a vlog anyway thanks
for watching I'll see you for the
hundredth you can model light as having
massive materials because it seems to
travel slower in them yeah but you can
also model a bubble as having negative
mass because it goes up instead of down
yeah wrap your head around that